what's happening you bad [__]
greetings from podcast village monday
august the 9th from the heart of new
jersey the joint is brought to you by
draftkings
listen everyone's favorite time of the
year is right around the [__] corner
football season and college football
season draft king sportsbook america's
top rated sportsbook app is here to
celebrate we're jumping up and down
draftkings is putting new players on the
first yard line with 203 bets instantly
just bet a dollar on any college
football game
take advantage of this limited time
offer now
draftkings has given all new players 203
bets instantly
when you place a dollar bet on ellie any
college football game
2000 and free bets is yours no matter
what happens during the game
download the draftking sportsbook app
today right now monday use promo code
joey and receive
203 bets when you place a bet on any
college football game that's promo code
joey to get you 203 bets instantly for a
limited time only i hope you guys
went to draftkings last week for louis
gaines and bet and got a hundred dollars
on a dollar bet i know a lot of you did
so hopefully you're jumping on this
college football [__] deal right now
only at draftkings sportsbook new
customers only must be 21 or older new
jersey indiana pennsylvania only
see draftkings.com
for details now if you got a gaming
problem you got to call 1-800 gambler if
you're in indiana
you call you got to call 1-809 with it
but if you're straight download the
draftking sportsbook app today and win
some [__] getus the winter's
coming and you want to be prepared
draftkings.com sportsbook app not the
fantasy app the sportsbook app enter
code joey and turn a dollar into 200.
the joint is also brought to you by
better help you like joey what's better
help better help is who i use for
therapy better help is therapy for the
21st century this is not a crisis
hotline this is not a self-help
better help is a professional therapy
all online you schedule your weekly
video or phone search sessions
at your convenience you don't have to
sit in an uncomfortable waiting room or
lie on a [__] couch
they'll access all your needs match you
with a licensed therapist who is right
for you and finding a good match is
important
it's their number one priority and if
you ask me it's the most important part
of therapy you need someone you feel
like you could talk to so do me a favor
right now
go to betterhelp to have an offer for
uncle joey's joint listeners visit
betterhelp.com
diaz for 10 off your first month that's
diaz for 10 off your first month
better help
b-e-t-t-e-r help
h-e-l-p-com
for 10 off your first month get better
help and start living a happier life
today as you guys notice it's working
for your uncle joey and also i want to
thank you guys that have gone over to
the ice cream shop
to get some [__] laughing gas
tremendous
i smoked it one of the nights this week
i [__] was drooling from everywhere
my nose is even dripping but anyway
go to laughing gas in studio city and
get your batch of [__]
laughing gas here you go [__]
the joint is coming at you on a monday
morning
tip top [__] magoo
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday welcome to the joint it's
monday august the 9th
my [__] cousin's birthday i gotta
give him a call i never talked to my
cousin i only talked to him on his
[__] birthday i call him he lives in
miami we grew up together
i don't know what's his problem he
doesn't say much
but uh he doesn't say [__] i don't hear
from him all [__] year
and today i call him he picks up on the
second ring how you doing it's been a
great weekend everything was beautiful
i'm feeling a lot better you could tell
i got a little bit more [__] nip to
my bite
the only thing that's left is my [__]
rash all of a sudden my wrath i've had
this rash for 10 [__] years a little
spot and also that blew up under my
armpit it must be the [__] heat
i went to the doctor we went over my
blood test there's nothing wrong with me
i got the [__] uh
mickey mantle gene like bert kreischer
it don't look like i'm gonna die it was
just uh
it's just a [__] you know between the
knee
the [__] gums i gotta go back to the
dentist today
uh we're getting older but we're getting
wiser and we're getting stronger i saw
this weekend
that rogan was getting [__] on uh on
twitter because of something he saw on
the podcast last week
yeah and i got to tell you the truth
i agree with the guy what he's saying
listen i only got vaccinated because one
it was one shot
i just wanted to do it because i knew
that this was gonna happen i knew that
they were gonna start playing
that you gotta get vaccinated scene i'm
not like jennifer aniston i didn't stop
talking to friends we didn't get that
you know what the [__] is that i stopped
talking to certain people because they
didn't get vaccinated no in fact the guy
i hang out with the toughest
hasn't gotten vaccinated because he got
coveted already and he won't get
vaccinated but now listen he works in
new york city so now he's in a [__]
dilemma what do you [__] do
that's the reason i got vaccinated i'm
usually an anti-vac i don't get the flu
shot i don't like [__] needles but i
had a funny feeling i knew where this
was gonna go and like i said i didn't do
the [__] whole process i just did the
one johnson johnson i gotta be honest
with you i don't even know what was in
that [__] thing
because i got a headache for two days i
didn't get no sniffles i didn't get no
diarrhea i didn't fart i didn't get sick
i didn't cough i didn't get a
temperature so between you and i i don't
even know what the [__] was in there if
you guys think i believe the [__]
hype i don't i believe this hype though
this hype what do you do now you can't
perform in new york
you know all comics are mad and listen i
agree with them this is uh
uh something that we've never [__]
experienced before but
welcome to the new [__] world you
wanted it you got it [__] you guys
wanted the zombie apocalypse and the
walking dead well here we have it
[__] you know you got the walking
[__] dead and i don't know what the
[__] to do i'm just doing
i'm just minding my [__] business
that's you know
rogan said something in that little
speech that i've been saying for [__]
for a year and i didn't just say it i
did something
rogan said that throughout this pandemic
they've been pushing all this [__] on
you but nobody nobody said to you to get
healthy nobody said to get in shape
nobody told you to get look at your life
and see what you were doing wrong and
what things you could change and you
nobody told you that nobody figured that
out i figured out i ended up losing 40
[__] pounds i ended up switching my
[__] reefer schedule around i slowed
down on the [__] drugs i slowed down
the [__] edibles i sleep better i
drink water all [__] day i walk a
minimum of four [__] points on weight
watchers a day on top of my workout i
looked at things to make me stronger and
to make me healthier at this [__] age
i'm at that age where you know the
reason why i didn't smoke pot all those
months because i didn't want to [__]
get sick that's one of the
prerequisites of smoking they'll [__]
with your [__] coven and everything
else so i didn't now i'm smoking again
i'm happy everything's [__] tip top
magoo and i'm ready to [__] move on i
don't have anything on my agenda i'm
gonna go away at the end of the month or
maybe the beginning of september to
[__] shoot a tv show i just
negotiated everything everything is tip
top and we're going we're ready to go
but besides that i'm minding my [__]
business i ain't got doing dick people
were like you you walked out of guns and
roses i didn't go to guns and roses the
reason why i didn't go was because there
were 60 000 people breathing
jumping up and down and i could go see
him in september with 17 000 people
and who knows who knows what my fate is
but me i like to play the [__]
percentages i'm a man of many [__]
percentages you understand me remember
five points becomes something
after a [__] year or two so don't
ever give up on [__] percentages what
i want to talk to you [__] about
this week is what happened to me this
week i had an interesting [__] week
for starters tuesday
was was the 42nd anniversary death
anniversary of one of my best friends of
all time
i woke up august 3rd and i knew
something was off
and i'm like i wonder what the [__] is i
know that you know because i always have
a date for everything you guys know i
have a date for everything august 3rd
was the day that my friend dominic
speciale drowned
august 4th was
40 something years since i saw ted
nugent and bond scott
at the garden they even talked about on
aussie's boneyard on wednesday i'm like
holy [__] i was there so every date has
something august 9th is my cousin's
birthday every date
has a certain [__] meaning to me so
tuesday was dominic's uh death
anniversary he died in 80. so it was
really 41 years it's been 42 years since
i taught ted
and [__] bon scott at the garden that
was a complete different story and then
i saw him august first ac dc
with brian johnson at the palladium with
def leppard so
listen i'm a man of many [__] dates
i'm a man of many dates i'm a man of
many percentages i'm a man of many
[__] whatevers a lot of mistakes
but
tuesday was the anniversary i remembered
i called
her brother her sister
his sister
and i said i was thinking about dominic
we spoke for a couple minutes
and then wednesday i got a call
from
a girl that was here sunday
she came down to visit me sunday i had
some company on sunday and she was one
of the people that came over her name
was lisa we went to grammar school
together and she was going to see
another friend of mine from grammar
school and she stopped over here first
i gave her a little bud we talked some
[__] she brought her dog we had a great
time but
she said to me that
wednesday she called out of the blue
and said that our friend louie
the
called me
and called her and wanted to get my
number and talk to me
louie is a kid that moved to north
bergen
when i got left back in the seventh
grade that first year when i got left
back he moved to north bergen
uh we became tight and
you know we were friends throughout high
school and then we
we all went out different ways and i saw
him again in 93 when i was delivering
sandwiches for hash way on kennedy
boulevard and he pulled over and we
spoke a little bit and i you know i was
just trying to keep it together and we
spoke but we haven't spoken since uh
august or september of 93.
when lisa called me wednesday she didn't
call me just for the louie thing
she called me to tell me that one of the
guys i grew up with that's my age he's a
lot older than me
but i used to do little side jobs for
him he used to get me inside jobs if you
know what i mean to look at the safe and
to look at the security in a warehouse
so he would get me a job there for two
weeks he knew people was always an
inside job
and i'd tell him exactly where the doors
were where the cameras were whatever you
know i would just break the place down
from but i was dear friends with him i
was a lot younger than he was
and uh
she called me to say that her daughter
had died
she's 38 years old she died a [__]
pneumonia covid and uh
a cardiac arrest you know and i didn't i
hadn't spoke i hadn't seen her in 30
years if you want me to lie to you now
i saw when she was a little girl with
him you know with the dad
and uh you know it's not like i was
tight with her or anything but
she knew how much i cared about the debt
so she was telling me that you know when
we hung up the phone
i was like [__] life is crazy you
know 38 year old girl she just got
[__] married
she went to some [__] parade caught
covered and the rest was [__] history
but
thursday morning i didn't even really
think about i just said a prayer for
that's all you could do when somebody
[__] punches the ticket and say a
prayer for them and move the [__] on i
mean what can you do you know i'm used
to it
but then the next day
i went to pick mercy up at camp we got
home and i went out in the balcony for a
while and the phone rang and it was
louie lisa had given louie my number
louis
you know he's not louie no more he's
[__] 58 years old
and he called and we it was a great
conversation like i told you guys a
couple months ago that
so far all the people i've connected
with the people that i've
i've really hit home with are the people
that i went to graham in school with for
some reason or another there's like
seven of them
and we're tighter than [__] and we talk
you know all the time
and now people are starting more people
because they found out that you know me
and ralph carey talked me and dave ruiz
talk me and lucio talk we all talk
chucky mcbreen so all of us went to
mckinley we were all we've all been
tight
since the seventh grade why the seventh
grade because uncle joey was a [__]
[__] and got left back in the seventh
grade and it was weird because
when i first went to mckinley i went i
signed up for the sixth grade i got
thrown out of [__] sacred heart
for attacking sister heisent and then my
mother made me go to public school
yeah it's behind me here sister hyacinth
and then my mother made me go to public
school
so
i i wasn't sure what i was going to do i
didn't know if i was going to go to
school in new york
union city and i finally decided [__]
i don't want no drama i don't want to
have to drive in the morning
i'll just go to [__] school in north
bergen no big [__] deal
so i went to mckinley and i got to tell
you something i had a great time in the
sixth grade i had a great time i had mr
lavito as a teacher he used to tell me
that if i wanted to talk during class
that if i didn't talk he would let me go
up in the front of the classroom on
monday on friday afternoons and sing so
i would wear like a nice shirt and sing
like frankie valley songs [__] sherry
and my eyes adored you don't don't don't
repeat that to nobody is between us i
was a little geeky of a [__] i thought
it was a crooner i would sing in close
to the girls and i would tell me to go
away and [__] it was
you know whatever the [__] i was doing
wasn't working
so the seventh grade at mckinley the
first time i did it
i got left back because i fell in love
with a girl and we were dry humping you
know you know the [__] deal and i got
all [__] and [__] i went to summer
school and i played hooky from summer
school and i failed summer school so i
got
left back but
before i got left back i got to be
honest with you guys the kids i was
running with
that were
i think they were a little older than i
was half of them were like six months
because my birthday's in february i
don't know what the [__] was going on
but a lot of them were older than me
a lot of the kids
were a little wilder than me
i didn't really fit
with that group of kids and i still
remember going from the sixth to the
seventh grade
thinking to myself i don't really fit
with these kids like i liked north
bergen then but it wasn't my [__]
favorite and then
i met anthony balzano to be honest i was
jimmy balzano's age
anthony was a year younger than me but
anthony hung out with dominic and hung
out with
just so many [__] cool kids sabatino
they all hung out together i used to
hang out with like hal and all these
older kids and it wasn't just getting
anywhere we were just it was more of a
motorcycle relationship we all had
motorcycles once i fell off the
motorcycle and got the concussion and
stopped riding motorcycles
we kind of lost who the [__] we were you
know
even john bender all those guys they
were a year older than me i got along
with them but my heart was really with
anthony and those younger guys so
when i got left back it was like a
[__]
it was like a sign from god you know i
was upset that i got left back i felt
like a [__] [__] you know to get
left back you have to be a [__] [__]
so there was nothing i could do i
thought carmine was gonna be able to fix
it for me at the board of ed but that
wasn't gonna happen you can't
[__] [__] around with school records
so i took the seventh grade like a man i
shut my mouth and that was the first
time i said i have to re-haul my life
and in the seventh grade
was where i was smart enough to go you
know what i got to stop doing what i'm
doing i got to pay attention to my
grades and i got to re-haul my life and
i remember i dove into karate
and i dove into [__] basketball i
didn't care about girls anymore
you know i didn't care about sucking
tits behind the church all i want to do
is whack off and be left to [__] alone i
got heartbroken in the seventh grade i
ended up getting left back over it [__]
it i'm not doing this ever [__] again
i'll be a monk i don't give a [__] in
the seventh grade when i got left back i
was never gonna get laid again if it
meant being hurt i was never gonna suck
titties again i was never gonna date a
girl again i i wasn't gonna switch
governments i wasn't gonna be gay but i
wasn't gonna [__] around with girls
until i got my life together and that's
exactly what i did but in the meantime
i was going to karate and i was playing
basketball
and
i really my my first year in the seventh
grade
i was allowed to play basketball and we
went owen [__] seven or some [__]
and i just couldn't live with that i was
like that that's it
these guys are graduating they're moving
on it's basically our [__] team
so when i got into seventh grade our
eighth grade basketball team was
basically us there was a couple of
eighth graders but not really it was
basically us
and two kids moved to the neighborhood
one puerto rican kid his name was raul
he moved right across the street from me
and
while he was moving you know how you
usually move you put stuff in and you go
get more stuff while they were moving me
and my pack of buddies
dominic rested soul his brother mike
sabs a bunch of us broke into raul's
house and i stole his [__] stereo
with his speakers i gave the speakers to
dominic i kept the stereo the stereo was
a cassette eight-track turntable combo
not cool in those days but you had to
settle for those because somebody cool
would come over and go yeah you got a
cool stereo but if the eight track
breaks then your whole system's [__]
up so you have to get like a fisher uh
component and then get a cassette deck
and get a turntable all separate and get
a receiver you know that's what the
[__] professionals want to do i
didn't listen to him i did it my [__]
way i got tremendous [__] speakers
that somebody stole off a train and sold
them to me brand new and i hooked it up
with the [__] turntable i stole from
raul but guess what raul was a
tremendous basketball player and we
became friends
so rahul would come over to my house but
i wouldn't let him up to my bedroom we
would have to go into the basement so i
always always said to me how come i
never go to your bedroom to listen to
albums ah i go my bedroom's [__]
dirty nobody's allowed in there for
[__] a year raul lived across the
street he came over to my house every
[__] day and i let never let him up
in the bedroom all my other friends
would go out and go oh we're at coco's
house we listen to [__] albums all
night and [__] and he'd go how come you
never invite me i'm like cause you're
never around that was a lie he lived
right across the street from me he was
always [__] around
but
the neighbor was hot raul finally left
there like in the eighth grade but raul
was a good basketball player and we got
another addition to the team and his
name was louie
lewis had moved from houston street
in the village
uh he came to mckinley why i don't know
he moved to north bergen
he lived on the 26th street side um
his family had just had a loss
and
he was a great basketball player he
could [__] jump he was a dominican
kid with a little afro
and i remember we used to smoke pot like
our whole relationship with these kids
dominic
anthony
louie dave
chucky except for chucky chucky never
smoked pot but the worst thing we did as
kids
was we get high up in the woods and then
we
take louie and we blow pot smoke into
his afro
and it would be dark out and if the moon
was out you would look at the moon and
all of a sudden you would see the smoke
come out of louie's afro we thought that
was the coolest [__] thing in the
world every time we got high with louie
that's what we'd do when he get high
he'd always look at me and go did
anybody tell you you look like a meal
because i had a really long face when i
was [__] 12 or 13. so he used to call
me the mule every time he'd see me go
meal meal meal
so
the other day when i talk to him i go
you still call me the meal and he goes
do you remember that i go [__] i never
forgot i used to look at myself in the
mirror every day when i was 12 and go i
don't look like a mule i look like a
monkey so
so [__] uh
louie was a great kid you know and he
made a great addition to the basketball
team i think our [__]
our seventh grade we went like three and
four we didn't go we didn't have a
winning season but it was a lot better
than being all in seven
and we became tight
we just
all of us became so [__] tight
it was pathetic mckinley rocked to
we had a [__] rocking little class it
was louie lisa messina
orlando saucedo
we were [__] hell on teachers hell
i remember a seventh grade teacher quit
and we had substitutes for like a month
and all of them wouldn't come back we
would [__] put them through hell and
when we got to the eighth grade
we were fired the [__] up
fired the [__] up in fact our first day
in the eighth grade
was the last day of seventh grade and i
remember the teacher said before you
guys even get settled
i want to talk to you
she's like listen
you guys have a reputation
for being [__] savages
that [__] ends now today i want you guys
to go home for the summer and know
that what you guys been doing in the
school is not going to be accepted next
year i am going to start suspending
people
the whole [__] thing and she was dead
set against it let me tell you something
we broke that [__] lady
we broke her like in february we were so
[__] tight
we used to go to shop right at lunchtime
steal hubba bubba
all of us would put a 10 pack of hubba
bubba down our [__] pants
and then we'd go to class chew the hubba
bubba and whip it at each other in the
afternoons until somebody [__] got
hurt you know i mean
six seven pieces in your mouth at one
time we would make huge spitballs our
spit balls were so big we couldn't even
use the straw we would just whip them i
put like eight pieces of [__] paper
in my mouth drink a little [__] water
from that the cancer faucet
and i'd put that [__] ball together
and that whole
dog she would be up on the blackboard
and [__] paper would just be on the
top of the blackboard you would see like
six feet of [__] uh of wall and it
would just be covered with huge
spitballs and you'd see the drip of the
saliva going down it was [__]
disgusting but we were professionals
orlando saucedo dave colombo
bishop i mean we were [__]
we had an italian immigrant kid michael
alegretta we used to whip him with the
[__] hockey sticks and he'd go yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he could speak english i mean we were
[__] savages but in turn it made us
tighter as [__] we were tight as [__]
no coke no acid no booze no nothing we
were just pot smokers once a week on
saturday nights we were athletes first
and pot smokers [__] second
and that neighborhood was packed with
kids when i tell you
that my childhood before my mother died
was [__]
tremendous
i even talked to lisa about it after
louie called me i was like how many
[__] kids were in that neighborhood
we had five kids per every seven houses
we counted them the other day we had
seven to eight kids on each block
so you have liberty avenue charles court
given that terrace 38th street and 39th
street that's [__] 35 of us that were
tight from the [__] eighth grade
that's the number i mean it was we would
go out in like a [__] 16 17 of us
we'd walk up the hill to union city and
there'd be 16 coming at you and we'd
have a stack of girls walking behind us
because we watched those girls and those
days nobody was into [__] sucking we
watched those girls like they were our
littlest [__] sister
when i moved back to jersey last august
19th
after about six days we were bored we
were middle sex middletown where the
[__] we were staying
at corporate housing and i said to my
wife do you want to take a ride to north
bergen and she goes absolutely i go
we'll go eat
say hello to some people and take a ride
and that's exactly what we did
and route 3 to come south
is my old neighborhood you know you have
to go down
liberty avenue you catch the three east
or three west and that hooks you into
the turnpike which
hooks you into the parkway
and i'll never forget i took my wife
there
in 2016 we took mercy to the same park i
used to play at 38th street park
and then we went to the cemetery this
time i attacked it
from the chinese store on the top of
37th street all the way down
took them by the park
took them the long way through 39th
street 38th street
showed them where i lived with the
benders jackie garcia's house kathy
moran's hot just showed him all these
places one on 38th street showed him
carmine valzano's house what they had
already seen
i took them through charles court and
pointed out the houses and then i took
him on given that terrorist which they
had seen before
and my wife looked over at me and she
goes i gotta be as honest i can with you
this [__] neighborhood
is dead
and i told i said terry
after
speciale died in the summer of 80 august
3rd 1980
it sucked the energy out of this
this neighborhood was done
it was done after that we all went our
separate ways
and the neighborhood stayed there to
[__] rot
there's not a kid on the street i've
driven by there at four o'clock
there's not a soul on that [__] park
on 38th street let me tell you something
we were on 37th street i'm sorry 37th
street park 37th street park they would
be
when i was growing up there would be 40
kids on that [__] court
there would be 20 kids on that park and
the park even came with a milf
the chick that i wanted to attack and
[__] suck at titties and [__] i still
go visit her in jackson she's like 70
now 80.
faye was the milf on the block with the
two french [__] poodles the park was
complete
that neighborhood was a [__] great
neighborhood to be a kid it's basically
like the neighborhood i live in now for
kids
everybody had pool there was a thousand
things to do
if you wanted to break a window you
could break a window if you wanted to
steal down the trains you could steal
down the trains if you wanted to torture
the chinese guy at the [__] store you
could torture him if you wanted to
torture the guys that owned this big
store on third on
liberty avenue you could torture them i
mean the [__]
the neighborhood was a kid's paradise
everybody you could knock on people's
door everybody would say you want water
drink it from the [__] faucet from
the hose outside
carmine balzano had a built-in pool you
could always go over there and eat it
was just a paradise
but all that ended i tried to explain it
to my wife and she was like i can't
comprehend what you're saying because i
never saw what it was
when louie called me thursday night we
were talking
and he was like it was great to see you
i saw you in the longest yard but you
know we got that out of the way
and he dropped on me
he goes you know i think about our
situation all the time he lives in
rutherford new jersey and he said he was
walking down the street
and he saw a guy that resembled me and
he thought about me
and he thought about my mother and
that's why he goes it was time to call
you and when lisa said that she was
communicating with you
i told lisa i want to talk to you but
after seeing that and getting that
memory
and he said he goes when i see you
when i see you in a movie or whatever i
think of your mom
and i think of my brother
because the reason why he left the
village was because his brother died
so the family wanted to get out of that
house where they lived the apartment
where they lived
and they moved to north bergen so when
he came to north bergen he was at my
house all the time i mean i had a
basketball court i had the above ground
pool
you know i loved kids coming over the
[__] house not a lot of them
but the main ones i liked chucky coming
over i liked david ruiz lucio would come
over lucio was the [__] commissioner
in union city
and he had like a little bit of a big
chin at the time and i'll never forget
one time we were bench pressing in my
backyard and he wasn't that strong and
he went to grab the weights and the
weights just came right down on his
[__] chin till this day his chin goes
out a little bit we used to call him the
chin after that
but all of us were that
[__] tight
so when i talked to louisiana on the
phone
the first thing he said you know after
we went through the [__] of you know
after you don't talk to somebody for
nine years or whatever it's been about
20 [__] years since we spoke
he said to me
he goes you know man i don't want to
bring it up but he goes do you still
think about your mom and i'm like all
the [__] time
he goes do you still think about anthony
balzano i go all the [__] time you
know
he goes do you still think about dominic
i go how funny is it that it was his
anniversary
two days ago
and he goes uh
that's crazy because i've been thinking
about you guys since like monday we
spoke thursday
and we spoke for like 40 minutes it was
a great conversation i cried i don't
know if he cried you know i i didn't
make it obvious that i was crying i just
felt the tears roaming down my face
before we move on i want to talk to you
guys about some i told you in the
beginning of the show we got a new
sponsor better help
better help is who's
who i've been working with
when my friend when i was looking for a
therapist a psychiatrist whatever
i called a friend of mine and we were
just talking i go i gotta find the
therapist or something
and she goes no no no call contact go
online and go to betterhelp.com
sign up
it's a monthly service they help you
pick a therapist
and they uh
it's it's great i didn't know what to
expect
you know i had never seen a therapist or
psychiatrist one-on-one i didn't know
what the [__] to expect
but i tell you what i was blown the [__]
away
against my better judgment better help
listen what's standing in the way of you
achieving your goals
figure it out with better help like i
said i've been with better help
since uh may so may june july
and now august i paid again
they're a great system okay it's
therapist better help is therapy for the
21st century it ain't a crisis line this
ain't a 1-800 line this is not self-help
better help is professional therapy
online okay
you could do this it's all remote
it's flexible you could schedule your
own things you could message your
therapist during the week if there's a
problem
and it's affordable that's why i like it
the most i wasn't gonna pay you know
they're telling you that all the
therapists and psychiatrists and
everybody's book solid all the good ones
yeah they are but better help offer me a
girl named dana a woman named dana who's
worked with me from day one and i got to
be honest she's great this new joey d as
you see is from her little talks from me
it took me a couple weeks to get loose
two or three weeks i'm not gonna lie to
you i have never been familiarized with
therapy before but this works it's
inexpensive it's cheap and they do a
phenomenal job you booked it
you booked the job right on the computer
you booked the therapist right on the
computer let me read it to you so we
don't have any
they asked us your needs and match you
with a licensed therapist who is right
for you finding a good match is their
number one priority and if you ask me
the most important part of therapy is
that you need
someone you feel like you can talk to
dana was that person for me when you
sign up you can start talking to a
therapist in less than 48 hours there's
no waiting around and they sent and you
can send messages to your therapist
anytime they'll get back to you
in between sessions
if you want to switch therapists you can
do so at any time for free better help
makes it easy better help is 100 remote
and available worldwide
plus better help is more affordable than
traditional
therapy and financial aid is available
okay
trust me it helps to have someone
outside your world to talk to i didn't
know that and it's easy to schedule
affordable and i'll take a load off your
shoulders
that took a load off my shoulders i feel
a little better i look a lot better over
a million people have taken charge of
their mental health with better help and
they offer a special discount to uncle
joey's joint all right i'm going to give
you 10 off your first month when you
press in
code diaz so do me a favor visit
betterhelp.com
and put in diaz for 10 off your first
month that's better help help h e l p
dot com
slash diaz you know how to spell better
b e t t e r
dot com
slash diaz
ten percent off your first month
betterhelp.com
diaz it's that easy listen
if there's no [__] a shame or
anything i'm not ashamed of getting help
why would i be ashamed of getting help
it's gonna make me a better person and
it's going to help me achieve my goals
it's going to help me be a better dad
and i got to be honest here they've
helped so go to betterhelp.com right now
use diaz and get 10 off your first month
you won't be [__] sorry you did it
trust me what i'm telling you you're
gonna enjoy it they have great
therapists i have two other friends that
are doing betterhelp.com right now
and they always get back to me and go my
therapist is great one of my friends has
a man
my other one of my friends has a woman i
have a woman she's phenomenal we usually
talk on monday mornings at 9 30. you can
schedule whatever you want go to
betterhelp.com right now
slash joey you will not be sorry i'm
going to get you 10 off on your first
month back to the louis story so
when louis called the other day
he we just talked about all the things
we did as kids
he still remembered us listening to
richard pryor
he still remembered us going to see
satellite fever
in jersey city we all went down there
and like i told you it would be a crew
of [__] 12 or 13 of us he remembers
still going down to see the pink panther
in jersey city he remembered all these
little things from my life
but towards the middle of the
conversation
when he dropped
the biggest bomb on me that he could
ever drop
and i thought about my wife he goes
you know
we had a rough childhood
that was a rough rough childhood because
we had the world by the balls it was
funny i was in the car
uh friday with mercy i took it a
kickboxing and i thought
studio 54 was on on you know on sirius
xm
i thought i was listening to studio 54
because they were playing like a disco
type jam
and all sudden they switched to this
other song baby come back
[__] great song you know a love song
came out in the 70s and i looked it to
see what was on i go why would they play
rock music
on studio 54 radio when i went to look i
go oh [__]
it's 70s you know 70s on seven whatever
the [__] it is it was some 70s show
and i was like wow the [__] 70s had
some great [__] music the 70s had
some great moments
for us
the 70s were great as kids we all
started hanging out like in 76
75 i moved to north bergen in 73. so
you know all these kids i had become
friends with like anthony balzano all of
them we all came to fruition i remember
1976 we went on boulevard east and we
cut the [__] chain off a parking lot
and we were charging like two bucks to
[__] park to watch the celebration on
hudson river i mean we were we were
little [__] gangsters but we didn't
give a [__] we were hustlers we had a
good time but the most important thing
is
that's where i learned
to live for one another as a friend
we all we needed like i said all you
need is three friends you could take
over the world where i got that
mentality from
was what we were doing in the [__]
70s we were that
[__] tight
and we were having
the best [__] summers
and after
the seventh grade that we went three and
four
and then we hung out the whole [__]
summer going into the eighth grade i
went to basketball camp in jersey city i
think david ruiz came with me i went to
booze basketball camp in vineland new
jersey
chucky came with me [__] raffle i
mean a bunch of us we would take over
again when we went to that camp in the
eighth grade we [__] them up too we
put shampoo on one of the council's
[__] sneakers we stole his t-shirt i
mean north bergen represented
anywhere we went when i went to joe
namath football camp i went with chuckie
mcbreen
when i went to five star i went with
greg horrendon and you know i had billy
herrenda on the church of what's
happening now listen this my jimmy runs
deep with these young [__] savages
so
it was funny the other day louie said
you know we were just talking he goes
you know
how
downtown ended was very sad and i go
jesus christ we were in the eighth grade
having a blast
i mean
it was just great the eighth grade was
phenomenal because my stepdad had moved
out of the house
my mother hit him with a [__] saint
on the head and he was bleeding
everywhere he left thank god i pushed
him out of the [__] house it was my
hand because
i had to get my [__] off in the eighth
grade he was blocked he was [__]
blocking me not that we were getting
[__] or nothing like that i just wanted
to be a [__] wild man with my friends
we were going to jersey city we were
going into the city and watching [__]
three card monty games we would smoke
pot and go into the city and [__]
just
we would try to sneak into strip clubs
like there'd be a guy out front that
he'd go come on in get a drink you know
how many times went into strip clubs and
we had chicks sitting on our [__]
legs when we were in the eighth grade
and they go all right well you're going
to buy me a bottle of champagne and
those days they had like a little bottle
of champagne and this is all up along
broadway in new york city guys this was
buck wild we they'd sit on our laps and
also they go buy us champagne how much
is the champagne 20 of glass all of us
would squeeze that tit one last [__]
time then the bouncer would come and
throw us out and we leave there with our
faces red we all had little hard-ons i
don't know if you guys remember the
story when all of us [__] ordered the
porno movies and it came with a
projected three of like seven of us me
louie michael speciale
was so young he started [__] crying
when he saw the lady sucking the dick
he's like what is that i'm scared he
started crying we got to walk downstairs
this is the kind of [__]
we were doing as kids
we were in the real world and
i was taking all my buddies up to my
mother's bar in the afternoon after
basketball like we were hungry or
thirsty i go [__] it all of us let's go
to my mother's bar i would walk into my
mother's bar 10 deep she'd go jesus
[__] christ and we would sit at the
bar and i'd make the bar tend to give us
all a coke and we'd put a cherry in it
make believe we were like gangsters like
we'd be like look at us drinking that a
[__] bar because we sit at a bar they
would go back and tell everybody we were
sitting up at the [__] bar with men
my friends that wouldn't go to the bar
with me would lose their [__] minds
but that all came to an end and let me
tell you
what louis said to me that really [__]
me up
he said that what happened to us in the
eighth ninth tenth grade
to find who we are for the rest of our
lives
and he's absolutely right
because
one night
in may at the beginning of may
we had already finished the season
our eighth grade year was so [__]
wild
because as soon as we got into the
eighth grade there was two women eighth
grade teachers there was miss
walsh who was our teacher and ms verga
who was the other eighth grade teacher
the other savages
started throwing spitballs at her and
[__] and she just quit
she just quit on the first day of eighth
grade she goes i'm too old for this
i'm not gonna do with these guys we
already had a reputation she walked out
of the class and they replaced her with
the mayor of weehawk and his name was
wally lindsay that's a complete
different story we don't have that much
time today to go into that one but that
was also a [__] kick in the balls
because he had an assistant named turk
jordan and we'll get into that some
other time he took us to the nick game
he showed up with a [__] passed out
stripper one day with the tits out and
he's like [__] in the eighth grade we
got tons of story about that he tried to
cheer us up
you know we had the coach that [__]
called me a [__] and then i ended up
finger banging his sister and the father
caught me so the word on the street was
he was gonna kill me so we were like
[__] it if he's going to kill me we're
going to kill them that's how tight we
were
we were going to kill the basketball
coach
in the 8th grade
stab him and put him on route 3 because
at the time this is how crazy we were
at the time
and if you go if you live in jersey or
in the new york city area brooklyn
connecticut you want to go for a day
trip you can check this [__]
information out but i'm telling you
mckinley school is on route 3 all the
way
up north if you're headed to new york
city and you're on route 3 and you're
headed into the lincoln tunnel you're
going to pass mckinley on the left-hand
side it's next to this [__]
embroidery thing and then you have like
shoprite and then you get lost in union
city you hit weehawken and you make that
turn if you watch the sopranos when he
gets off the toll
the jersey in the beginning woke up this
morning and he swings around that's
weehawken making a hard [__] left
into union city which takes you into
[__] north bergen if you're coming
that way from new york city you'll see
mckinley on the right hand side and the
york motel on the left-hand side the
york motel is not called the york
anymore double check it online for me
but i think it's not called new york but
it could be the york motel was a dump a
dump they were finding dead hookers in
there once a [__] month when we were
kids we would go to the lobby to get
potato chips with mckinley and we'd
always see disgusting people in there
[__] guys with [__] rashes around
their mouth we would see some nightmares
[__] in there it was it was a rat trap
of a hotel but we were in the eighth
grade the iceman the real iceman richard
kulinski i didn't know this i did not
know this in the eighth grade i found
out years later he cut a guy in half and
he put him under a bed well we were in
the school when he did it like we saw
the ambulances going over there we
weren't allowed over there for three
days they had police tape so in our mind
we were gonna kill [__] the gym
we were gonna kill the basketball coach
whatever georgie frank we were gonna
kill him we waited for him with the
lights off in the gym we had sticks we
had crowbars we had a basketball we had
a [__] neck to choke him oh yeah we
were going to hit him in the head with a
basketball we were kids we tried to get
all the makeshift weapons we could and
then we were going to [__] drag him
out to route 3 and put them across the
street from the york motel and they
would think it was the same guy who cut
the guy in half we didn't know was the
ice man at the time when i saw the
interview with the iceman i'm like holy
[__] it was you cut the body in half we
were in the eighth grade we still
[__] remember
but
louis said that what we went through
all those years
defined who we are and made us [__]
stronger
the three people who died the four
people who died one of us had nothing to
do with us
but she had something to do with me
we had a great eighth grade [__] year
we went to philly
we went to the nutcrackers we we went to
what's that [__] lady's name who made
the flag betsy ross we went to the house
we went to the house got thrown out of
there we got thrown out of the
nutcracker suite because we were
shooting the people in the play with
paper clips and rubber bands so they're
trying to [__] do the nutcracker and
they're going ow wow cause we're [__]
whipping them with the thing we got
thrown out of the movie theater then
they took us to uh hiram's up in fort
lee and we got hot dogs and [__] and
[__] you who's and we were singing
you know three cheese for the bus driver
the bus driver the bus busting his balls
the whole [__] way but that all ended
that all ended one night with me
anthony
dominic
louis
we were all playing basketball on 37th
street court
mrs balzano called for anthony
said anthony dinner and they turned
around and said coax you coming over i
go no my mom's home tonight i'm gonna
[__] eat you know my mom's cooked
something for good for me
louie was there we all said our goodbyes
louie went into the woods with the other
guys from 26th street and they were cut
through the shop right i went home and i
remember the next day
i went to [__] in the eighth grade and
before i walked into the class
mr barone took me aside and he goes did
you hear what happened last night i go
no
he goes anthony bonzano got in a bad car
accident with his brother and tweeds
this kid stephen edwards that was older
than us
he goes he's in back
he's in bad shape he's in critical
condition
that destroyed us
we went to the hospital we hung out
in front of the hospital solidarity went
in
and then on uh
may 20 something
they took him off this stuff and he
died we never recovered from that
we
played it off we didn't really
i just kept playing basketball and i
kept going to his house and i was part
of that family now
and we got tighter
and then he passed away and
that was it you know we were
we were [__] mortified you know we
were just blown the [__] away
we were all there we saw him going to
his house
then we all went to high school we
stayed tight we all me louie dave ruiz
whitey
chucky we all played [__] freshman
basketball
we dedicate the season to anthony
we didn't do much everybody loved
anthony that whole team knew anthony we
were we were always out and about it it
hit hard
then freshman year i got a locker with
this girl rose andy agostino d
the agastino diaz we had to get
lockers with people in our homeroom
and she turned me on to this girl she
goes she doesn't like who she's sharing
a locker with
do you mind if she shares a locker with
you and i go no
and uh
somewhere in our freshman year she went
on a date
got in the car with some guy and and
they got into a car accident they both
died you know
but again it was very weird because i
saw that day in my lock i put the books
away
at that time i started feeling a little
[__] weird you know
but in the eighth grade something else
had happened
i started dating this girl named colleen
in union city she was one of my
cheerleaders
at st michael's
and uh
i'll never forget i went to a house
to swap spit whatever dry hump i had no
sexual intentions
she was a cute little redhead with
freckles irish chick i loved her to
death
i'll never forget sitting on a couch and
going what time's your dad get home and
she's like five o'clock
i'm like what time is your mom get home
she goes my mom is not alive my mom is
dead and i was like
i was like [__] this i and i freaked the
[__] i had never heard
of any mother's anybody's mother dying
i'd never heard that before
i was 13 years old i never heard that
your mother could die i thought mothers
were invincible
and i remember that i went home and i'm
not talking to that kiss of that no more
[__] what did you do that your
[__] mother died when you were like
five and
[__] maybe a year later i
did a head of acid
you know before i [__] left my mother
called we spoke like nothing happened
we spoke she says i don't feel good i'm
coming home early
you know i'll leave you something to eat
i got home she wasn't home
i woke up in the middle of night she was
[__] dead i had spoken to her that
afternoon
and then
a year [__] later you know after my
mom's dying i'm not even [__]
aware that my mom is dead yet i haven't
even
processed it
and i'm walking up giving that terrorist
to go get clothes at my house
and i see dominic speciale run out of
his house
and he
i go dominic where you going he goes i'm
going to the [__]
i forget what you call it now the quarry
there's a quarry in northern new jersey
where they all go
and he goes do you want to go i don't
even know if he asked me that i don't
want to say that
i just remember
him going i'm going to the quarry
and be going all right see you tonight
and
that night somebody knocked on my door
and said dominic had drowned at the
quarry
but
all four instances that i just told you
i saw those people
and i spoke to them and i got to
see them a few hours before
their tragedy ensued you know
and it was [__] surreal i don't think
i ever recovered
and it did define
who the [__] i am
because now when i see people before
they leave i always tell them i love
them
so i'm covered
i'm covered if anything happens
i did my peace i always when i
leave with people i always say i love
you these are the things i picked up
over the years the strength you pick up
i'll never forget somebody came up to me
a dear friend of mine he goes hey man
you know it's weird every time i talk to
ralphie
i talk to him like it's the last time
i'm i'm gonna see him and he's a good
friend of mine and i remember i got mad
at him
for a few days for saying that
and then i go you know what what the
[__] am i talking about it's the truth
he's right this could happen at any
[__] time
so that's why when you see people and
you're having a good time with them when
you're gonna go leave them don't take
that goodbye for granted
always look at them one last time and go
jesus christ i love you and that's it so
if you do get that call
you don't feel bad
you know i don't know if i did that with
anthony
i don't know if i did that with my
mother i don't know if i did that
with dominic you know i don't know if i
said those things but i know now
i do and it's because of that time that
we spent together we were young
we're planning to have a little
get-together
i might just call louie this week and
take a ride up to rutherford my teacher
is in town mr t
the guy who [__] took me in in 85 and
got me off the drugs and took me to aaa
meetings and helped me get to where i am
today
i'm gonna go visit him this week
he's uh staying somewhere down the shore
and uh
i'm gonna go talk to him because again
he's got to be close to his 80s
and i want to make sure i cover my
spread with this guy if something
happens he lives in sarasota florida
so
that's why the other night when lisa
called me and said
that that
girl that i had been friends with her
father died
i knew how to handle it yes i was a
little upset and yes i said a prayer
but i think that
what happened
to me as a child got me ready for
ralphie
you know [__] brody i couldn't be
ready for
because brody i got the call on a
[__] plane
when i was headed to las vegas to get on
stage what do you do you cancel the show
there's no [__] cancel on the show
you got to dig deep and be [__]
strong and that's what i did but all
those strengths
came from what i went through
in that downtown area in mckinley school
and i'm grateful to them and that's why
i think
that these are the guys right now
that i'm getting i'm
you know i'm [__] mixing with the
best
because our relationship was so strong
in 1977 78 79 and 80
that it can't be taken it's like
whenever i talk to these guys on the
phone we go right back to where the [__]
we were it's like nothing has been
no years have gone by it's like we were
in the eighth grade yesterday
so it's been the weirdest thing louie's
a social worker
he's got a degree in psychiatry
we spoke for a little while and i got to
be honest here
i felt a lot better since i've spoken to
him on thursday
my anxiety has disappeared a lot lower
it was like i i don't know i touched
god's hand or something by talking to
him it took me back that [__]
that much you know
right now this year the last two years
have been rough on us as americans as
human beings
as people you know with our friends our
family we've all
[__] gone through debt or whatever a
friend you know like i said to you i i
would love to sit here and tell you i
love so many people independent
i don't know i don't know
this is the first girl i remember that i
i know and
well tina petrillo the girl that used to
shove
bottles and a [__] and we were kids at
the strip club she died from covet last
year my heart goes out to her family
but
i never really knew anybody that passed
from covet or whatever
a lot of people are passing and a lot of
people are going through grief right now
i just want to let you know that we've
all gone through grief from one way or
another
you will survive and you will come out
at the other end of this but the most
important thing is
there's a silver lining to all this
so if somebody close to you and your
family has passed from covert
or whatever i know that right now you
want to reach through that [__]
video and smack me in the face
and go joey my mother died from colvin
how is there a silver lining to this
well listen
you're not gonna see it today you're
gonna see it sometime
in the next couple of years
how do i know because there's a silver
lining to any everything
my mom passed all my friends passed
i have all their pictures up around my
desk dominic
anthony
my mother and any other ones my soldiers
that have gone rhaego and i look at them
every day for strength
that's what pushes me through every day
when i wake up in the morning and i sit
there and i go i have anxiety like a [__]
i got to deal with this i got a knee i
got a [__] my gums are swollen i look
up and i see a picture of rhaego or i
see a picture of dominic or i see a
picture anthony balzano and i go what
the [__] am i complaining about
it puts everything else into perspective
so there's a silver lining to all this i
know like i said i know you're looking
at me going joey i don't know what the
[__] you're talking about
i'm telling you right now this is silva
even the covent
as bad as it's as has been there's been
a silver lining i got the best
message in the world on patreon on
saturday some guy signed up and i went
to throw my welcome [__] email and he
had already written me a [__] huge
email
saying that
he didn't like me before the pandemic
and that one day he listened to me that
i stayed on after rogan or something
our podcast went up and i said something
and he goes ever since that day he
started listening to me
and that he had a
uh airbnb he had 14 properties and that
all dried up
and all this [__] bad happened
but he learned how to do something else
during the pandemic
and now he's blossoming again the whole
thing so i know
there's always a silver lining that's
why
when i got the call the other day about
tommy's daughter
i thought about why i was so prepared
for that call
because what i went through as a child
prepared me for the rest of my life
to deal what i have to deal with if you
could deal with that
at 16 if you could deal with three
deaths including one being your mom
the rest of this [__] is background
[__] music
and that's the [__] joint for monday
august the 9th i hope
that this podcast gives you a little
light it gives you a little hope in your
life
and it lets you know that you're going
to be [__] fine
i want to thank
betterhelp.com i want to thank
draftkings for uh
sponsoring this podcast today and i want
to let you know it's all going to work
out no matter what's going on whether
you're vaccinated unvaccinated
it's all going to [__] work out just
believe in yourself
get healthy
take your vitamins get vitamin d
drink water smoke reefer get your dick
sucked and stay mentally on top of this
[__] game okay
things might get bad they might get
worse they might get good
all i want you is for you
to be mentally prepared and [__]
solid
so we're good august 9th is done this is
my message for the day
i'll see you [__] wednesday the
11th tip top magoo ready to [__] go
and now for a word from my [__]
sponsor love you
thank you bad [__] for watching
the joint today i know i took these into
a little deep water but i wanted to get
that off my chest had been
on my mind for a while the joint is
brought to you by better help we told
you in the beginning
and the middle of the show better help
is therapy for the 21st century
the better help is professional therapy
and it's all online and guess what it
works better help is 100 remote and
available worldwide you don't have to
live in a big city
to get quality therapy no more better
help has a special offer for all uncle
joey's joint listeners
visit betterhelp.com
diaz for ten percent off your first
month
better help
b-e-t-t-e-r help h-e-l-p dot com
slash diaz i'm gonna get you 10 off your
first month it's already affordable and
expensive you're gonna love better help
thank you for visiting and thank you for
taking the recommendation the joint is
also brought to you by draftkings
listen
in about two weeks everybody's favorite
time of the year is going to be here
what is that joey football season
college and pro but we're going to start
with college first draftking sportsbook
is america's top rated sports book app
and we're here to celebrate
sorry about that an old pubic hair got
caught on a [__] console you know
what i'm saying
draftkings is putting new players on the
first yard line with 200 and free bets
instantly just bet one dollar
on any college football game
did you hear me one dollar in any
college football game and they're gonna
give you 200 and free bets instantly
whether you win or lose who's better
than draftkings nobody head to draftking
sportsbook app right now to check out
all the great promotions
daily odd boost saturday they had an odd
boost for the ufc [__] tremendous
draftkings is
sportsbook is safe
secure reliable and they're based right
here in the u.s of a usa usa withdraw
your money at your convenience download
the draftking sports book app today use
promo code joey so you have it all ready
for college football bet the first
college football game for a dollar and
you're going to get 200
and free bets that's promo code joey to
get you 200 and free bets instantly for
a limited time only at draftkings
sportsbook new customers only you got to
be 21 or older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook
for details now you got a gaming problem
we got to take care of that call 1-800
gambler and if you're in indiana call
1-809 with it
but if you're straight download the
draftking sportsbook app today and win
some [__] getus and remember
you can't bet over your head with
draftkings you got to have money in
there so it's not like betting with a
[__] bookie and [__] this is all done
from the privacy your own home nobody
knows nothing again
draftkings.com download the draftking
sportsbook app use promo code joy to
receive 203 bets when you place a dollar
on any college football game i want to
thank draftkings i want to thank
betterhelp.com
diaz and i want to thank ice cream shop
dispensary in studio city for carrying
laughing gas and other reefers that'll
blow your [__] mind i'll see you
[__] wednesday
tip top magoo
ready to [__] go ready to stab
somebody i love you [__] have a
great monday have a great tuesday
and i'll see you wednesday
you